all right Nick
Nick where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um from Minnesota most of my life in
Minnesota I'd spent like four years in
Fargo
uh growing up Midwest Minnesota and
Fargo good childhood
yeah I it
I mean it was it was a little rough I
guess
in what ways
a lot of um
a lot of moving around a lot of uh
instability
yeah I didn't I I
um I didn't know my father until I was
in my teens oh really so I was moved
around a lot with my mom and introduced
to different guys
as a kid um
what kind of kid were you in high school
um I like to I like to goof around a lot
I have a class clown like to get in
trouble
i i a very big mouth
a very big mouth in high school what
kind of things did you want to do
for a career
um you know I wanted I wanted to get uh
in into the military photography when I
was really young and then when I got a
little older I wanted to get into the uh
the military
um
and I you know I guess I I as a kid I
didn't I lacked some clarity as a child
you know as far as like exactly what I
wanted I think a lot of kids do so I was
kind of confused
um as to direction and stuff like that
um but yeah my first I wanted to get
into photography then I wanted to get in
the military and then after that I ended
up getting into masonry working with my
hands
and you're currently about a bounty
hunter in Arizona yeah that's correct
it's uh uh technical term is the Arizona
State authorized Recovery Agent
well that's a fancy way of saying Bounty
Hunter yeah so I could explain to me and
the audience what a what a bounty hunter
is because I I thought I knew but I I
realized I don't really know exactly
what a bounty hunter is
um you're a cop no no we're not we're
not cops uh we do have to get cleared by
the state in Arizona every state is
different
um but in Arizona you do have to pass a
couple background checks and then pay
the department of insurance which is
overseen by the sheriff's department and
get approved to be able to do it and
then it's a pretty easy process once
you're approved uh they kick you out say
go pick people up
and what are you you're chasing people
that the cops have given up hunting for
um on some some of them yeah on some of
them
um the majority of them if if someone
bonds themselves out of jail it's it's
like privatized probation okay so
they're they're signing an agreement
with the bondsman saying I'm going to
add here to these terms and conditions
uh to the bond I'm gonna be good
basically yeah X Y and Z I'm going to
check in every week I'm going to pay you
the fines and fees to babysit me
basically
um and by doing so I'll be free and if I
if I do something to uh uh you know go
against the agreement that I made and
I'm not living up to the terms and the
conditions then my bond will be
terminated and I'll be sent back to jail
and what kind of people are you
typically people like robbery oh yeah
you you name it you name it all right
there's like nowadays there's a lot of
drugs
a lot of people have drug offenses
weapons charges
um burglary theft assault
we had uh someone who had murdered
someone uh this is just a month ago you
know
um you know and everybody you talk to
always says that they didn't do it and
everything else but
serious charges yeah and tell me how
does it go down how do you actually find
somebody how do you apprehend them well
so so if if they go warrant right by not
showing up to court
um that's part of the terms and
conditions on their bond they need to
show up to court
um so that the bond doesn't get uh
terminated right
um or forfeited because if that happens
The Bondsmen lose money so if if you are
uh warrant we're immediately going to
pick you up because the bond is in
Jeopardy of of being forfeited right so
if you do something you catch a new
charge or you don't go to court and now
you're Warren you're done you're getting
put back
um there's something called an
indemnator right an indemnator is
basically your co-signer on the bond
right your mom your girlfriend your
sister somebody that cares about you
right and you didn't have enough money
to put up uh everything on the bond so
they're going to put something up for
you and they're going to be your
co-signer that's called an indemnator
anytime that there's an indemnator that
person has the power to throw you back
in jail right because they they're the
cosigner on the bond if they say I don't
want to be liable for Jimmy running
around doing what he's doing anymore
he's going to get in trouble I want off
the bond the bondsman has no choice but
to immediately go and pick you up and
put you back in jail to Forfeit that
Bond
so that's what we do is we pick people
up for The Bondsmen uh if they've gone
warrant or if the indemnator says hey
this is a problem person or if they stop
checking in the bondsman says I don't
trust that this person is going to go to
go to court I think I'm gonna lose money
go pick them up and you get paid by how
many people you find or just yeah it's
you know you you you eat what you kill
man it's
commissions I guess
what kind of you must have some great
stories yeah
yeah there's there's been some really
crazy ones that's for sure uh six years
going on seven years
yeah
tell me tell me a crazy story or two
um
okay uh
that okay so we're on the I-10 we just
picked this guy up it was about two
years ago
um
in transport from where we picked him up
at his mom's house
to Fourth Ave jail we were using the
Fourth Ave jail in Phoenix at the time
for the sally port
this guy decides he wants to to be a
problem he ended up snapping his cuffs
okay the link
between the Cuffs that holds the Cuffs
together he's handcuffed behind his back
he ended up snapping it and so in
transport I see this vehicle ahead of me
I'm driving right behind my partner and
it just starts jumping around like I'm
like oh [__] something's going on the
dude's freaking out you know something's
happening the vehicle pulls over on the
side of the highway I pull over right
after it I get out and I see my partners
jump out of the vehicle and this dude
got out through the window that he had
kicked out and jumps out so we're on the
10 and there's Vehicles just flying by
right here right both the agents in the
front seat exit and get out this guy
crawls out the window and gets out this
way the guy in the front seat had a
pepper gel gun a pepper gel gun
is pepper spray with like a 410 shotgun
shot behind it so when it discharges
it's like it's there immediately and
it's Amber red burgundy red I mean it
looks like blood okay so when he lets
this thing off on this guy that's
crawling out from behind the car it
looks like to everyone passing by on the
highway that we just blew his head off
okay because it hits him in the face and
then it hits that concrete barrier
behind him just splatters all over it so
people just freaking out you know DPS
got called I knew right away I was like
oh [__] because you hear people
screaming on the highway so we got him
pulled off the side of the car so nobody
could see him anymore waited for DPS and
we're like look everybody's okay we
discharged the pepper gel gun nobody was
shot you know
um that one was kind of that one was
kind of comical I guess you know but a
little crazy you know you must be in
danger sometimes right oh 100 yeah 100
putting yourself into these
yeah situations are just going to be a
problem
yeah no one goes peacefully right
well no you know okay so so it's like a
percentage thing I'd say I'd say one in
five fights
20 of them have it in their head that no
matter what happens this is what I'm
gonna do I'm going to run no matter what
I'm going to not let the bounties take
me whether it's PD or the bounties
so it's about 20 you know
that fight
what's the most dangerous you've been in
um yeah I've been shot at
um I've I've disarmed people with guns
knives uh
I'd say probably the most dangerous
situations
are the ones where people's family
family members are around
um I use I use a shotgun with bean bags
in it now I have a sidearm too but the
shotgun with bean bags it um it breaks
them down pretty quick right so like if
you shoot somebody with a bean bag it's
pain compliance
and it mentally kind of collapses them
right so they're they're the any fight
that they had if you hit them with a
shotgun they think this person just shot
me right so there's there's a moment
where they just they kind of there's
they they freeze they don't know what to
do right if you do that in front of
someone's family
now that person's brother or mom or dad
thinks that you just shot and killed
this person okay and now they're
escalating the situation to a point
where it's out of control right they're
extremely emotional people are freaking
out
um those are probably the most dangerous
situations because there's too many
people in the house that I can't control
and I can't contain and they think that
I just killed a family member and I
don't have time to explain that to them
that it's a non-lethal round until it's
after it's already happened right he's
okay it's a non-lethorone please stay
back he's okay but those situations they
escalate and they get they get they get
crazy absolutely there's drugs involved
oh always there's always yeah almost
always drugs how many of the cases are
drug related
um
the majority of them 95 of them these
are these are people that are using
drugs yeah
what is the police department's view on
bounty hunters
um for the most part very reciprocal
um you know very good for the most part
every once in a while especially in
small towns you get uh police officers
that have never dealt with a recovery
agent before uh Bounty Hunter before so
that you know maybe they're a little
Territorial and they're like you know
what are you doing working in my town
yeah
yeah that's kind of what it comes down
to most of them the majority of of uh
police officers and law enforcement
agencies are very reciprocal majority
you know
do you have any particularly interesting
stories or just oh yeah yeah you know
absolutely
um You probably have an endless list of
them yeah I've got I've got a ton of
them I've got a ton of them
um
uh okay this one this one happened about
a year ago um and this one was was
particularly hard for me to deal with
because of the fact that I mean look it
gets violent sometimes it gets
aggressive it gets violent and and we
don't always push it into that we don't
push it in into that uh direction right
if it if it's things start getting
violent and and someone is not being
non-compliant and threatening me that's
not something that I can control right
but I'm also under the directive of the
bondsman so sometimes I'm being told to
do certain things that I might not uh
morally agree with right and the person
that hired me is asking me to do this
stuff
right um we had a guy who was mentally
ill I didn't know he was mentally ill
um until about an hour into it after he
had been
pepper sprayed and used pain compliance
on I forced him to walk
six blocks
to the courthouse
using pain compliance
I mean if you can imagine what that
would look like
um he's screaming for help
and I have to
stand him up every time he tries to sit
down with these handcuffs and wrench his
wrists behind his back so he stands back
up right and I finally got him down to
the court I mean like I said six blocks
my forearms were given out I can't even
imagine what his arms felt like being in
cuffs like that right
um
and he
was pepper sprayed he was not feeling
good I had people following me and
videotaping me the whole time right
and by the end of that day I was upset
because the bondsman
made the decision to drag him into the
courthouse okay against his will
saved himself ten thousand dollars by
doing that right
um but in turn had to pay me 2 000 and
then we had to brutalize this guy and
victimize this guy and like look I I get
it he put himself in that situation but
he was mentally ill this guy this guy
really uh couldn't make sense of what
was going on around him and I you know
pepper sprayed him put him in handcuffs
and Drug him for six blocks using pain
compliance and I
you know
it upset me because because
I had no backstory on this guy I didn't
know what he did to deserve this right
or if he did
um but I had I had to do what I had to
do I mean the bondsman hired me to make
sure he went to court and that's what we
did right
so situations like that can be alarming
sometimes to have to take a directive
from a bondsman and do something that
you might not feel is the right thing
I've seen families um
emptying out pillowcases with dollar
bills in it so that they can save their
oldest son from going to jail they're
trying to come up with 300 bucks so they
take the youngest son who's probably 11
and they take his piggy bank out and
they're counting out his money out of
his personal piggy bank while that kid's
sitting there crying
so they can save their older son from
going back to jail now
[Music]
the kid the older kid got in trouble and
put himself in that situation but it's
still heart-wrenching to see that it's
it's heart-wrenching to see someone
extorted for their freedom
you know these a lot of the people that
are out on bond
are in a rough spot right and
if you're going to be a a recovery agent
if you're going to be a bounty hunter
you got to get it into your head that I
didn't do this to these people I got a
job I got to do
you gotta you gotta have thick skin it's
what it is
um but there's definitely situations
where you look at it and you're like
that's you know that's not right I've
seen a I saw a girl go into treatment a
couple years ago uh bondsman wanted us
to go pick her up as she's checking in a
treatment not everybody thinks that if
they go to treatment they're safe
right I can check into this facility and
nothing's gonna happen to me well that's
absolutely not true okay
um if we make contact with you if you
flee from us I can I can I can pursue
you anywhere okay but this girl was
checking into treatment and we talked
her out of the facility from checking in
she came out in the parking lot you know
told her we weren't going to take her to
jail
put her in handcuffs took her to jail
okay
we lie a lot and we have to because
people don't tell us the truth but this
particular chick was uh was unsettling
because she told us that the bondsman
wanted her to sleep at his house and be
his roommate
and was trying to sleep with her and all
this other stuff so
when we find out why we're putting her
back and taking her out of this
treatment facility
right at this point I have her in my
custody I've put my bracelets on her if
I've put handcuffs on somebody
I can't just take them off and let him
go right because then that could leave
the opportunity open that I maybe I take
bribes
right I put handcuffs on and just if I
put handcuffs on somebody
they're gonna get put back right but it
it
um it highlights kind of like an
underbelly to the industry that is uh
that's that's not often seen and is is
kind of greasy
for sure
it's got to be a very stressful job
because
you know the drugs that are on the
street now especially like crystal meth
somebody goes five ten days without
sleep and they're having these psychotic
episodes then you're you're dealing with
somebody who's
out of their minds yeah yeah drugs um
you don't know until you start
interacting with them yeah yeah that's
uh drug drugs is a big problem you can
get a shout out just for pulling into
somebody's driveway yeah oh yeah yeah I
mean and you know we we trespass
you know we we go onto people's property
you know if there's not a a no
trespassing sign up even if there is you
know we're we're gonna go in there you
know so absolutely you got people coming
out and playing Guns at you all the time
and you know getting getting fired up
has your your family your loved ones
feel about the life you've chosen here
um
I wouldn't be doing this if my wife
wasn't okay with it
but she's got to be worried about you
she yeah right well but yeah but I also
don't tell her
you know the stuff that goes on it's
it's if I you know if I've had a long
day I'll come home she can tell
you know because I not very talkative my
nerves are shot but you know I don't
tell her half the [__] that happens I
wouldn't want to don't want to scare her
you know
do you do anything to help
decompress them at all
yeah catch the guy I'm after
but that helps decompress right I feel a
lot better you know right I just went
through five houses had to search Five
houses and had five different family
members tell me to go [__] myself in
five different ways by the time I catch
that person I'm I'm okay
I feel better about it what have you
learned about
he is
our society or human nature or whatever
well you know that's uh
um there's definitely there's definitely
times where you you where I I feel uh
hopelessness I guess
you know like like the direction that
everything's going in uh the homeless
the amount of drugs that are out there
um
you know the fact that people pull their
cameras out and videotape you while
while their friend is getting beat up
you know
um the the I watched a group of friends
not stand up for their friend but pull
out cameras and videotape their friend
get their ass whooped
you know and where I'm from where I grew
up you know uh
that's [__] up you don't do that your
friend's getting beat up you stand up
for them you know and that's the the
society nowadays it's I feel like
there's
uh not that many leaders out there
anymore
yeah there's not that many leaders out
there anymore there's not that many
people that know how to
um take accountability for their actions
own their actions and take
responsibility for it that's one thing
if I if I pick somebody up and you know
they're visibly high on fentanyl or meth
right and I say hey you know did you do
any drugs today what you got going on
um or or you know uh did you steal that
from your sister you know did you punch
your mom this morning that's why we're
here you know your mom's scared right
now did you punch her if if that guy
um comes to me and says hey you know I
[__] up I had a bad day you know I was
smoking meth this morning I got worked
up my mom said something to me and and
and I unloaded on her I will have so
much more respect for that person having
owned their actions versus uh picking
somebody up who is who is and this is
this is the majority of the people is oh
this is [__] up now why is this
happening to me man she's doing me wrong
she shouldn't be doing you know like
those are the people that that to me
uh you should go back to jail you're not
you're not ready to be out in society
yet you you you're victimizing people
you're not taking ownership for the
shitty things that you're doing you're
not a man
you know
um but I feel like that I feel like
there is there's uh that's missing
Society there's not a lot of leaders
there's not a lot of people that take
ownership for the [__] they do
oh you changed from your years doing
this
um
I've become a little more uh uh I guess
it thickens your skin up a little bit
you know I could get into a I can get
into a an altercation with somebody
and they could say whatever they want
about me and
I you know I don't care you can stick a
phone a foot from my face and call me a
[__] and a [__] and you know it's it's
not gonna phase me
um but uh
it's it's it's made me a little angry
with certain types of people
that's that's for sure
yeah Society seems to be
getting worse in some ways yeah you know
the the down and out the
under
you know the people that have very few
opportunities to get ahead in life are
just
doing whatever they can to find it you
know a quick lick a fast Buck or
whatever
yeah and they'll do whatever it takes to
get it yeah and that usually breaks the
law well absolutely and and and kind of
back going back to what I was saying
about uh not taking ownership there's
excuses for everything you know this is
why I did that
no you did that because you you felt
like doing that right somebody else
didn't make you do the shitty things
that you were just doing and and nobody
like I said that's what I've seen is
people don't take ownership for their
actions right and then the drugs I mean
you know someone who is all [__] up on
drugs I mean they're not
you can legally hold them accountable
for their actions right but you gotta
even question that because you know
someone's so high on drugs that they
don't know what the [__] they're doing
you know and that's what's going on
nowadays you got people running around
that are dangerous people
that that are willing to hurt other
people and not really realizing what
they're doing
what's your biggest fear when you're
doing this kind of work
um
probably the kids probably the youth um
I it's it's it's funny because I I don't
typically uh worry about myself
it's probably a weird thing
um
my biggest concern is probably the uh
the way things are going for society
that's probably my biggest concern
um now when I'm out when we're working I
have plenty of times where where I'll be
uh
about to do something that's dangerous
um and I start getting nervous right I
mean I think adrenaline is always a part
of it but I've
I've become so conditioned by doing this
now that I can identify my little
markers and the things that I'm doing
and I can say okay I feel like this
because this is dangerous right and
typically it's before like you know it's
a barricade situation
someone's inside of a room
screaming [__] you and the family's
saying he's got a gun in there okay
we'll go get them big Bounty Hunter okay
and it's at those moments where you find
out if the guys that are working with
you
can hold can can do it can handle the
pro can't handle the job
um but when that so typically when when
I'm in a situation like that there's a
moment a brief moment where I'm like
God I don't want to be here right now
I just wish I wasn't here right now
right and whenever that happens
um I identify it right away and I'm like
you're scared because it's dangerous
[__] pay attention right now right so
um with experience you start identifying
things that are going on around you and
some of the internal turmoil that you're
going on that's going on with you and
then you start identifying and say okay
this is what's going on I need to manage
myself
and pay attention were there things you
learned early on in this job that uh
really has helped you survive and avoid
those kind of things oh absolutely yeah
that's a great question yeah um so I had
uh
I had a guy named alpha alpha one and uh
whiskey the first team that I started
with okay
great guys
um
Alpha is X Special Forces he he helped
me
set up my kit my kit is my vest right
it's your gear so I have my gear set up
in a way where it's functional for me
when I when I started I had zero
experience I bought my bulletproof vest
and my boss who's a special forces
operator was like all right let me see
it and he knew because he had already
seen me put it on but in front of the
whole team he was like let's see it
let's put it on November and I put it on
and I put it on backwards I put my drag
handle right here you know and he just
he's rolling but he helped me kind of
dial in
um
how to treat people how to approach
people you got to be dynamic you have to
be intuitive
you got to be able to read a situation
you got to be able to know how to talk
to people and working with with uh with
art with Alpha he helped mold me and and
whiskey they really they really helped
mold me
um and taught me a lot yeah
and one of the biggest things that we do
is we get to drop on people right
if you don't give that person time to
make the situation dangerous
then the situation situation will become
dangerous if you manage it right
um so we get to drop on people right so
we'll surprise them so if I'm going to
approach somebody I'm going to do it in
a manner where I get right up on them
quicker than they can even understand
what's going on and then boom on the
ground bracelets leg irons gone yeah
because because you're not a police
officer do you still have the ability to
slap somebody on handcuffs and do
whatever you need to do
um in in regards to like what situation
because you know that they're
wanted
you can you just like move forward as if
they're a fugitive or whatever
um Wanted like felt like if they're a
warrant yeah like felony warrant yeah
yeah absolutely you know and citizens
can do that too
citizens can do that too most people are
very apprehensive to do that kind of
stuff because they're worried about
getting sued
um and because of the fact that I've
been doing this work now for years
that's another thing that I've kind of
learned I'm not I'm not I'm not scared
to interject myself into a situation
right like I've seen kidnappings
where people the 20 people stood by
while this lady was getting kidnapped
right because they're scared to do
something
right and so because I've been in the
mix of it you know when the [__] jumps
off
you know cool as a cucumber
ready for the party you know but and
that solely because of experience and
because of working with some of the guys
that I was able to work with right away
that that that showed me hey man when
it's time to get busy we go
you don't think about nothing else
it's go time yeah and you work as a team
absolutely yeah
yeah I got six guys on my team six great
guys on my team uh got Larry Curly and
mo
that's my point guys in the field
so that's those are all their you know
it's just like I'm November one because
of Nick you know it's it's based on the
the first letter of their name are there
stories of guys that have just gotten
hurt or killed or whatever yeah yeah on
the team on the team that I was working
so I started Black Flag security and
Recovery a year ago and before I was I
started my own thing I was working with
a team called Eagle Eye right not great
guys
a couple years before I had come on on
their team uh two bounty hunters have
been killed
uh in Phoenix when they were leaving uh
apartment complex
Alpha
um almost got shot in the face uh from
someone hiding in a closet
um that was right after I got on with
Alpha
so it is a lot of close calls um but it
was about six years ago that two
recovery agents bounty hunters got
killed in Phoenix
you ever reconsider your decision to do
this
yeah yeah you know it's normally it's
normally when when you're about to do
something dangerous right and that's
when it's it's the weirdest [__]
thing man you could be doing this for
weeks Chase somebody around searching
houses doing whatever
and then and then it gets real and it's
normally right at that moment in time
where you're like this isn't this this
is not safe I I need to pay attention
you know I've interviewed so many people
there seemed to be certain people who
have escaped death
even though they're asking to get
hurt or killed over and over again and
they just seem to be like you know
everyone around them has passed away
well you know it uh the drunk guy that
that you know gets into a vicious car
accident mangles his car kills a family
of five but he lives
you know it's it's always the guys that
throw caution Into The Wind that either
land on their feet miraculously or get
blown away yeah but do you do you feel
like you're one of those that's just
meant to survive
um yeah wow that's a really good
question yeah I guess uh you kind of
have to be I think honestly I I
I think I'm not going to let that happen
and I know deep down inside that that's
that that I don't have any say in it if
the situation arises it's going to be
out of my control but I think going
um head first
through a door where someone's armed on
the other side I think you I think you
kind of have to just say I'm gonna be
okay
all right we're gonna we're gonna
I'm not gonna let this person act like
this I'm not going to let this person
put me in a box I'm not gonna let him
threaten his family he's not going to
threaten my my teammates right I'm if
there's a you know you take it personal
sometimes actually not sometimes all the
time if someone makes a situation
dangerous and barricades on me
it upsets me
and it then and at that point then it
takes everything I have to stay
professional once we've got him under
control and not do something that is
uncalled for right but
I yeah I take it personal if someone
puts me in a dangerous situation it
pisses me off you know I get I get I'll
I'll self-reflect for a second I'll be
like I don't want to be here and then I
normally snap right back to and I'm like
[__] this I'm I'm gonna manage this this
dude's done adrenaline's a hell of a
drug isn't it yeah
yeah it is are you in a adrenaline
junkie you know I never really thought I
never really thought I was but I think I
think I am a little bit
yeah I think so because I uh this would
be a career that
would be right up that an alley for
somebody that doesn't yeah
yeah
well you got to know yourself right I've
been doing Jiu Jitsu and martial arts
for like years right so like
and and lots of firearms training
disarming training stuff like that so so
if I get into a situation where I have
to put my hands on somebody I'm pretty
confident that I'm just my I'm going to
be able to do what I need to do to be
okay right now am I going to go jump on
a bull at a rodeo and ride a bull no
right like right like I know that thing
can bust my back in half your battles I
choose my battles and and I so you know
uh you know it is an adrenaline thing I
think yeah but you have an appetite for
risk as well
ah nah I'm really God you know I'm
really kind yeah it's so weird because
I'm really kind of a safe guy like I'm
really worried about safety with my
family and friends and stuff if I see
him doing something that I you know I'm
like hey you got to make sure you lock
that door you know you got to make sure
you do this you know it's not safe X Y
and Z so I'm kind of a stickler for
safety but then when it comes to my own
safety
I do I'll just I'll throw I'll throw
caution into the wind and see where
let's see where the chips lie bro
Nick what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um most important lesson uh
there's there's a few of them can I can
I say a few of them absolutely
um if you're smart there are a few
there's yeah there's a lot all right
No One's Gonna Do It For You
okay
um
nothing great happens
because you're scared
right so don't let fear
uh uh hold you back that's a great one
right because at the end of the day
nothing is safe that you're doing
right
um I'd say nothing great that you want
to see happen in your life is going to
happen because you're
afraid to do something yeah fear might
save your life but it's it's it might
save your life but it's a uh it's it's
not it's not going to help you in
relationships
it's going to make you build up walls
and it's not going to help you in
conquering uh your goals
and aspirations you can't can't be
scared yeah right yeah I believe in that
one wholeheartedly yeah
do you ever go on
uh Bounty hunts where you you don't get
paid
you know at the very beginning uh
absolutely you you have to commit
yourself everybody wants to be a bounty
hunter
um in the beginning uh because it's
glamorous to them they think it's a it's
going to be a fun job I want to say I'm
a bounty hunter but the reality is is
that if you don't know what you're doing
you're not going to make any money
okay no one's going to hire you not
knowing what you're doing you need to
have experience so you need to get in
with a team that's actually out there
working
um and at the very beginning man it's
your sacrifice you're the low man on the
totem pole so you know if the team made
ten thousand dollars you're gonna get
the scraps right while you're learning
so you're not going to make much money
uh your first year two years doing it
that's why there's a lot of Fallout and
a lot of people don't do it um
I guess there's two different ones where
I didn't get paid for
um doing it I was just in the right
place at the right time while some of
this happened but they they kind of
stand out to me as
um
opportunities that I had to to hold
someone accountable in a situation where
uh nobody else was going to right
um you know there was a a kidnapping one
night we were sitting at a uh a
laundromat
and I was doing surveillance on a
vehicle we were watching to see if this
guy would show up and drive this vehicle
away
um and in in the strip mall there's a
laundromat here there's 20 people doing
their laundry and this young blonde uh
lady pulls up in an Isuzu Trooper Parks
it gets out gets her laundry and goes in
uh probably early 20s good looking girl
and it was it was a really shitty part
of town so she kind of like stood out as
like a you know good looking young lady
that was walking in there and about an
hour later we're still in the parking
lot doing surveillance she comes out uh
goes to the back for vehicle opens up
the hatch
sets her clothes in there and as she's
doing it there's this you know probably
six foot three tall lanky prison tatted
up uh uh a guy walking up to her kind of
like slinking behind her car looking
like he's sneaking around right and
we're wondering like you know what's
going on here so we're watching and as
she puts her laundry in the back of the
vehicle he Bear Hugs her and drags her
alongside of the vehicle opens the door
and throws her in okay jumps in the
driver's seat starts the vehicle backs
up hits a light pole all of her laundry
and [__] comes flying out of the vehicle
and then he gases it out of the the
parking lot and the whole time we can
hear her screaming help me he's taking
me okay so my partner and I put it in
Drive
we start pursuing the vehicle we get
probably a half a block away and the
vehicle comes to an abrupt stop in the
middle of the street right and I knew
right at that moment I was like this is
my chance
to to stop this my chance to get up
there because if this vehicle gets away
from us we could lose him
he could end up killing her who knows
what's going to happen he could run into
somebody while he's trying to flee you
guys are armed oh absolutely yeah we're
all geared up
uh so the vehicle stops and my partner
said he has a flash of before he put it
into park man of me getting out of the
passenger seat and flying in front of
the vehicle and I was able to get to the
driver's side door
and as I got to the door I see him with
her head shoved down into the
floorboards and he's just [__]
drilling her in the head just punching
her so I reach in through the window and
I throw the vehicle into Park
and as I'm throwing it into park he
notices me reaching into the vehicle at
which point I was able to reach under
his armpit and yank him halfway out the
window
and as his head cleared the part where
the the glass is I was able to use kind
of the door frame to choke his head and
I pulled his head down and he started
squirming and making sounds my partner
pulled the door open we got him out
I pulled him around to the front of the
vehicle and he's resisting me
so
I my adrenaline's going I'm amped up
this guy is trying to kidnap a young
lady
I'm upset okay so he's fighting with me
and during this time uh he ended up
getting his head banged against the car
uh a few times
and then handcuffed
and dropped uh dropped on his ass and
I'm pretty sure that that banging his
head off of the car that many times put
him into shock because when we we
dropped him on his hands his wrist
snapped uh audibly like loud snapped
um and he didn't do anything he just sat
there kind of in shock
uh when the cops got there she was a
mess she's screaming she's saying thank
you so much you saved me thank you and
this guy's just you know he couldn't
even talk he's mumbling there's teeth
falling out of his mouth his arm is
wrist broken
um
but I I just remember that feeling from
that night that I got now this is a very
violent uh encounter
but it made me feel so good inside
knowing that I stopped her from being
victimized by this guy
right and I didn't get paid for that
right and there's a lot of times in
situations like that where you don't get
paid there's another guy that was
beating on his pregnant girlfriend he he
we're at a gas station the end of the
night I'm getting gas I'm I'm burnt out
I've been working for 10 hours doing
surveillance we didn't catch a guy I'm
frustrated okay I'm not making any
[__] money I just worked for 10 hours
for nothing okay and and I hear uh this
guy you know [__] you [__] you know get
the [__] out the cars in my car [__]
and it's in this Honda and I look over
and this dude gets out of the passenger
seat of this Honda walks around to the
driver's seat and grabs this chick by
her hair and throws her on the ground
and kicks her
and he and this is south Phoenix he goes
to get back in the driver's seat and at
this point man I'm already I'm already
to the car I mean I saw this going down
and I was just waiting for it because
I'm like dude if you do the wrong thing
right now I'm gonna be on you and he did
uh by the time he sat back down in the
car I was able to yank him out of the
car
by his ears not as okay not nicely okay
I got I got a way of grabbing people it
hurts I grabbed him by his ears I yank
him off the car I dumped him on the
ground gave him a swift kick
and she stood up and she's like sir sir
she's pregnant
okay
so I'm having a conversation with him
right as as I you know tuned him up a
couple times bent them over the back
side of the car and I'm like you think
you're tough buddy you think you're
tough
kicking a [__] pregnant woman and at
that point you know there's blood coming
down from his face he's oh sir sir and
it's it kills me how
guys who victimize women and children
will will turn around when they're being
held accountable and immediately say Sir
they start in with that sir [__] and
it's like you listen if I would have ran
into you five [__] minutes ago and I
was talking to you like a gentleman and
treating you with respect you wouldn't
call me sir
not even one bit you know but now
because I bounce your head off the car
because I kicked you a couple times
because I stopped you from beating your
pregnant girlfriend now I'm sir right
and it always blows me away that uh the
girlfriend always wants to advocate for
him oh his his grandma just died he's
having a hard time this and so I stopped
you know I let him go I look at her I'm
like you you want to leave with this guy
and she's like yeah and I'm like are you
okay are you sure you want to leave with
this guy yeah yeah we're good sir
and they took off and drove away and out
the the likelihood of me doing anything
that did anything to help them not have
to deal with that in the future he most
likely got upset with her and beat her
ass at a later date for it but the point
is is that maybe just maybe
holding him accountable that day you
know did something
so but yeah some of the best some of
some of the best things that I think
that I've done to help people uh you
know I haven't got paid for you know and
it's just being there at the right time
to be able to help people and and one
last thing if if you're a man
and you're watching someone victimize
someone else
right
um I feel like you're obligated to say
something and do something about it and
I think that's another thing that a lot
of people nowadays have lost
all right Nick thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah thank you
excellent interesting talk yeah thank
you very much thanks